if we're here for anything it's to
experience beauty and to recognize it
and shout it from the rooftops when we
see it and to celebrate it and if you
just do that in your day to day if you
dig into beauty and you start making
sure that everything you do is ground it
back to a pursuit of beauty and you're
gonna find a different life and you will
save the American people from collapse
in the process and you will show the
world that we can build a nation that's
not about empires and sequestration of
power and wealth and resources were
about create co-creation I think that's
one of the shining lights of the
American people as we are a family
creative group because we've been
empowered at the self level if we start
to mimic the communication network that
we found in the microbiome and we start
to build societies like that that's how
we're going to escape this extinction
event that we're headed towards and we
can start doing it by just being a
co-creative Society again connecting
humans to be co-creative rather than
consumptive and the world is our oyster
that's Zach Bush MD and this is the
ritual podcast
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing are you hanging in there
how is the sequestration going the
physical distancing how are the loved
ones holding up how is the close
proximity impacting your relationships
with those with whom you have
sequestered I'm rich role and I hope
you're taking care of yourselves because
this my friends is not a drill this is
not the moment to slack off it is indeed
self-care go time now more than ever
it's time to eat the good foods get the
sleep drink the fluids move the body and
to get creative with your families with
your kids and of course with yourself
and I think without of course minimizing
the extreme severe hardship so many of
us are currently facing at the same time
I really can't overstate the
unprecedented opportunity that we're
being gifted with right now to go inward
to confront and overcome the fear that
accompanies our inability to control
what is happening and instead invest in
the things that we can control our minds
our bodies our emotional state our
spiritual state and I think of it much
like an addicts moment of clarity this
truly singular and shared moment that we
find ourselves in that presents us with
this opportunity to look at and
hopefully break the chains of denial
that imprison us this occasion to
examine and reimagine behaviors that
don't serve us an economic system that
demands constant growth at the cost of
the collective good a political system
that preys on fear to divide us a
conglomerated food apparatus that foment
disease and then the pharmaceutical
complex that then relies upon those
diseases to create dependency and
ultimately this collective obsession
that we have with ego with power with
money and material consumption that
is rapidly eroding our biosphere and
degrading our integrity and separating
us from ourselves and from others and
from our innate divinity and my hope is
that we can emerge from this collective
experience this hardship this massive
planetary wake-up call
not as victims but empowered armed with
greater clarity to reimagine and
ultimately actualize a better more
sustainable purposeful intentional and
fulfilling life experience for ourselves
for our loved ones for future
generations and frankly the world at
large and look it's hard I know there's
a lot of suffering right now lives are
being lost jobs are disappearing layoffs
are happening everywhere the economy is
teetering and we just don't know what
the future will bring which is
admittedly truly scary and yet when you
cut through all the fear the anxiety and
the uncertainty I see humanity rising I
see incredible creativity everywhere I
look and I'm uplifted by the heroes that
walk among us so many selfless Souls
putting themselves in harm's way
sacrificing their own personal
well-being to treat the ill and provide
us with food and the critical goods and
services that we need to survive so
please don't let this pass without
reflection this is not the moment for
Netflix and chill but to engage your
imagination to recognize the opportunity
for reinvention to find the sliver of
joy that it presents to celebrate our
shared humanity to confront and accept
and embrace and find grace in the
essential truth that despite the chaos
amidst the chaos that control is and has
always been an illusion we never truly
know what the future holds all we have
is this moment and the choices it
presents but that being said I can think
of few people better equipped to
traverse
this terrain then my friend dr. Zack
Bush alongside me today for his fourth
appearance on the show it was recorded
just a few days ago it is well worth
your undivided attention and it's coming
up in a few but first we're brought to
you today by athletic greens
if you've tuned in to this show I
suspect that you already know how I feel
about keeping your nutrition in check
bottom line it is the key to optimal
health maximum recovery and performance
gains look nobody maintains an
absolutely perfect diet 100% of the time
so it's important to have a nutritional
insurance policy to make sure that your
body is getting the essentials it needs
on the daily I've tried a lot of this
stuff out there some are better than
others most products for me are one and
done but I got to say that athletic
greens ultimate daily formula has really
stood the test of time and has become
this critical component in my everyday
regimen and there's a couple important
reasons for this one it's super
convenient I keep the travel packs in my
car in my backpack and in my office so I
always have a healthy go to second
it tastes damn good and it dissolves
super easy these are highly underrated
pluses but most importantly it's an
all-in-one superfood powerhouse replete
with all the essential vitamins and
minerals 75 different Whole Foods
sourced ingredients scientifically
designed to not only improve immunity
but also increase energy support
recovery gut health and healthy aging
which is super important to me
everything is sustainably sourced
there's nothing artificial there's no
harmful ingredients it's vegan it's also
gluten and dairy free no added sugar
just all the good stuff if you're in the
US Canada the UK or Europe you can get
20 free travel packs valued at $79 with
your first purchase when you go to
athletic greens calm forward-slash rich
roll that's athletic greens calm for /
rich roll take your nutrition to the
next level with athletic greens
we're also brought to you today by
health IQ because life insurance my
friends needed a reboot just as you are
taking responsibility for your nutrition
I got an inkling you're also
taking responsibility for your health
and for your fitness should that be the
case as I suspect I'm also willing to
bet that you're overpaying for your life
insurance because for whatever strange
reason life insurance companies
historically don't take proactive
healthy lifestyle factors into account
when calculating your premiums and that
is just not right so health IQ was
founded to do what makes sense reward
your healthy lifestyle with rates that
take your healthy habits into account
here's how they do it health IQ puts on
the propeller hat and uses science and
data to secure lower rates for fit and
healthy people they can save you up to
41 percent because the physically active
have significantly lower risks for heart
disease cancer and diabetes science
people to see if you qualify go to
health IQ comm for its lush rich roll
and take their health IQ quiz depending
upon your score as well as other related
qualifying factors you can save up to
41% on your life insurance premiums
compared to other providers there's no
commitment and you'll learn even more
about potential opportunities to be
rewarded for your commitment to living
healthy one more time go to health
iq.com slash rich roll and finally we're
brought to you by expressvpn you've
heard me talk about the importance of
having a VPN before but in case you
don't have one look you got to get one
ace up because protecting your personal
data online is no longer negotiable it's
just a must I was a lawyer for many
years and so I understand the impact of
sensitive data falling into the wrong
hands and I have several friends who've
suffered the horrible consequence of
identity theft you don't want that and
as somebody who travels a ton at least
until recently and spends more time than
I care to admit on sketchy public Wi-Fi
in hotel rooms and coffee shops I've
learned just how vulnerable we all are
and thus how crucial it is to protect
yourself with a VPN I've done my
research I've tried a bunch of VPNs and
I can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best on the market
here's why first expressvpn doesn't
log your data unlike lots of really
cheap or free VPNs which make money by
selling your data to ad companies in
fact expressvpn developed a specific
technology called trusted server that
makes it impossible for their servers to
log any of your info the second is speed
many VPNs slow your connection down or
make your device sluggish I've been
using expressvpn for over a year now
with zero negative impact on my internet
speed or my device speed but the thing
that really sets VPN apart is how easy
it is to use you don't have to input or
program anything you just fire up the
app and click one button and you're
connected that's it so protect yourself
with the VPN that I use and trust use my
link Express VPN comm slash rich roll
and get an extra three months free on a
one-year package that's Express VPN com
slash rich roll visit expressvpn dot-com
slash which roll to learn more Zack Bush
you know this guy right he's a show
favorite longtime listeners are
well-acquainted with today's guest by
way of his many past appearances in
addition to being a renowned
multidisciplinary physician of internal
medicine endocrinology and hospice care
as well as a recognized educator on the
microbiome zack is also the founder of
seraphic group which is an organization
devoted to root cause solutions for
human and ecological health he's also
the founder of farmers footprint a
nonprofit coalition of farmers educators
doctors scientists and business leaders
aiming to expose the human and
environmental impacts of chemical
farming and offer a path forward helping
farmers with transition to regenerative
agricultural practices to me beyond the
resume Zack is point blank a master
healer he's a friend he's a critical
voice in the conversation we need to
have in this unprecedented moment of
global calamity and he's here today to
share his unique
perspective on the corona virus epidemic
what is happening how to best navigate
it what it signifies for Humanity social
economic and political systems and the
future of planetary ecology this is my
first attempt in many years since the
earliest days of the podcast in fact at
recording a podcast remotely and I admit
to a great aversion and almost allergic
reaction to this dynamic being
physically present with the person I'm
speaking with is at the very core of
what I do
however sequestration demands I adapt
and so this is my fairly reluctant
attempt to do just that
therefore you're gonna have to excuse
the audio quality although our voices
are perfectly understandable it remains
a somewhat eroded version of what you
come to expect the bandwidth at my home
is subpar a function of living a bit in
the middle of nowhere
Zack was recording from Oahu which also
doesn't have great internet and this
combined produced a latent delay and
required that we avoid talking over each
other which impeded the natural
conversational flow and our ability to
communicate organically and making for
more of a staccato back and forth kind
of exchange but disclaimer aside and is
always the case with Zack I think it
will find this to be equal parts
instructive enlightening and moving
especially the end so please listen all
the way to the end Zack has a knack for
landing our podcasts with unmatched
profundity and what is essentially a
masterclass in thinking both deeply and
broadly about this unique situation we
are collectively experiencing I love
this man I'm grateful for his wisdom and
I'm proud to share it with you guys
today so without further ado this is me
and dr. Zack Bush
in thinking about who I wanted to talk
to about you know what's happening
globally and the plight and the
opportunity that humanity is currently
facing I could think of no better person
to host this conversation with me than
yourself so thanks for coming on the
show today and perhaps we can just open
it up with you know how are you faring
and you know navigating all of this I
know you were in Fiji and now you're in
Oahu yeah it's been a very smooth
process for me I know there's a lot of
people that are under more severe dress
around the world right now but the last
month of travel has been interesting for
me and that I've gotten to see a number
of different you know peoples and
cultures responding to this global
emergency and Australia was interesting
space to be in there certainly a sense
of we've been there done that
in regards to apocalyptic disasters
there in Australia they just came to the
fires and I think that they're very
aware that there is you know a stressor
going on on this planet in regard to
ecological physical stress that's
unprecedented in scale and they've lived
through that and many have died in that
and the tragedies at the humanitarian
level one side but then just the loss of
life of animals and everything else was
just of a scale that really has not been
seen and so I think this feels like you
know a much lesser evil in some ways
than the apocalyptic fires had and so I
think there's a different energy there
than we see in the United States and
then in Fiji you know you're looking at
a developed country or developing
country that it has no infrastructure at
play and I started my medical journey in
the Philippines and did six months of
work with an international group of
midwives they are birthing babies in the
squats of the Philippines and was
routinely in hospitals that never have
any resources you know and so I think
when you're in a few
your Philippines or Africa or you know
some parts of Central America in these
warm toward countries Honduras and the
like you know the this is a daily plight
for them they never have the resources
to deliver the health care that you know
the modern technology would be capable
of they never have adequate supplies
they never have adequate beds to address
it they don't have the expertise to
address just the the usual and so what
we're experienced in the United States
particularly in New York City right now
is intense and my my heart and gratitude
goes out to those doctors that are in
the midst of overwhelming demand on the
on their system there in New York but I
think as a country we do need to be
cognizant of just how dire the situation
is day in and day out just to deliver a
normal care and so much of the world and
running out of hospital masks and things
like that is I think the rest of the
world might look at that and be like
well join the join the party and right
here is here is Daedra our version of
what it's like to be in the developing
world and being very much caught off
guard you know there's the perspective
of us just being you know horrific ly
unprepared to manage what's coming at us
and what's developing it's such a rapid
pace but also this sense that it's a
it's a trial run for something most much
worse and you know I I hold out hope not
to minimize what's happening at all
because it's it's absolutely horrific
but that it will be a wake-up call for
us moving forward to get our act
together not just in the United States
but globally so that we can unite and be
better prepared for when a more virulent
version of what we're experiencing right
now inevitably visits us yeah I think
that that's the unfortunate reality I've
gotten some flashback for some of the
comments of
made towards that end on social media
and such this reminding ourselves that
you know not only is this not as bad as
it could be it's going to get worse if
we continue on our course and people
have said you're downplaying this and I
think my point is no I'm actually
applying this like this is literally a
symptom of collapse of biology on the
planet and if we do not pay heed and if
we just continue to blame this virus as
if this is our problem then we're not
but then we're gonna walk into the
collapse of civilization we're going to
walk into the claps of an entire species
over the next hundred years and what
does that kind of look like it's
certainly getting not gonna look like
intact supply chains and intact you know
electricity and plumbing and everything
else that we're enjoying right now in
this country like I really think that if
if we continue to walk by these warning
signs of climate change you know fires
in Australia you know all the way down
to you know our public health crisis
with chronic diseases if we continue
walk by these and you know boom own our
problems or whatever and not start to
really fundamentally change who we are
and how we act on this planet this is
just the the slightest of warm-ups or
you know curtain calls for for what's to
come and it was heartbreaking that this
is all preventable we know how to change
the course of history and we're not
doing it and so I agree with you that we
need to be sobered by this when you take
the full impact of loss of life that
we've seen across the world the full
impact of the economic and financial
crisis that's upon families certainly
you know in the United States but again
just having been in a developed country
you know Fiji is really concerned
because they are a cash society that
lives you know day-to-day subsistence
and they're all being told there's not
going to be any of your primary industry
of tourism coming into your country for
probably six months and
you know so that it's you can't measure
that on the US mindset you know a scale
of what's happening around the world as
we make these decisions so I think that
we have to be constantly putting the
current situation in the perspective of
the greater context if it's going to be
teaching us the lessons that I really
believe this fiers is trying to teach us
mm-hmm what is uniquely distinct about
this situation is that no life is left
unaffected you know in contrast to you
know the horrific fires in Australia or
even 9/11 on some level in the current
scenario whether you're the shopkeeper
or the billionaire or the homeless
person or you know the average you know
soccer mom there is no person who is
unaffected by what's happening and what
makes that interesting is it's
incredible power to unite us around a
singular cause and the optimist in me is
hopeful that not only will this be a
wake-up call but it will be a trigger
that will set in motion a series of
events that will you know hopefully
change our current operating system and
how we're treading on the planet and yet
at the same time I just oppose that
against the power structure that
currently exists and I see the
opportunity for a tremendous
consolidation of power in this moment
which causes me concerned and so I'm
interested in in you know how you know
this sort of war between optimism and
pessimism works in your mind as usual
you frame things so beautifully that's a
perfect description of the situation
we're in
have been struggling to to explain that
situation you know in other spaces in
social media and everything else without
upsetting people because the natural
reaction unfortunately in our current
vibration as humanity is not to go to
that space of singularity of oh my gosh
we are all one we are all in this
together whether we're an earthworm or a
human or Chinese or American we're in
this together isn't hot the reaction and
I still am amazed that that doesn't work
because it seems so obvious like this is
the thing this is our opportunity let's
rise let's let's break down the
boundaries let's break down the barriers
let's break down the nationalism let's
break and yet the vibration we're still
stuck in is is that fear resonates
better than in hope and we're in a state
where you know retracting to likeness
rather than you know wholeness is what
we tend to do and so I got totally
attacked last Friday on social media for
mentioning that China is actually
successfully getting on top of their
situation and they're seeing a massive
reduction in the crisis on their side
and the amount of negative energy
towards China was unbelievable and on
the comments they were saying well I
don't believe anything coming out of
China that their draconian measures blah
blah their military state well they have
made some really drastic changes that
they felt like were necessary to protect
a population at one point to eight
billion people and it's not done how
things are done the United States and
their people may protest on some level
but they successfully got on their
problem and yeah there's a lot of
evidence that they got on it very
quickly in the sense that they they
started six new hospitals in the capital
of
you know the epicenter there and all six
of those you know hospitals have already
shut their doors because they were able
to empty them out so that Minh credible
speed at which they were able to achieve
those results and they're really looking
to the fact that yes the the measures of
that they took were probably helping it
but they also are doing a lot of work
right now brilliant Chinese scientists
right now doing the more important work
in some ways of saying why were people
died who was dying and it wasn't from
the virus because the virus didn't
affect most people severely and and so
they're really working hard and that
some great papers are coming out just
when a couple days ago came out and I
was brilliant looking at the microbiome
of of those that died and it seems to be
a unifying effect more than even ages
you know the collapse of the microbiome
the gut was predicting vulnerability to
this virus and so I see our Chinese you
know cepacia it's in science and in in
you know real critical thought here be
really leading the charge on helping the
rest of the world and yet the world is
making these you know horrific lis
closed-minded statements and belief
systems about you know this country
that's working so hard to recover from
what is undoubtedly the biggest you know
economic blow they've ever had and
interestingly at the same time we have
in the same series of comments you see
people you know complaining that because
Chinese supply lines have been shut down
their Hospital doesn't have enough masks
and everything else and so it it's just
interesting that as a country we go into
this nationalistic mindset we go into
this you know everybody else is evil and
we're the were the white horse and we
trust our media but Chinese media is
lying to us all the time and how can
possibly be trusting our media and all
of a sudden because certainly right
before this happened we didn't trust our
media and so why in a time of crisis do
we suddenly blindly think that the
United States is the the harbinger of
all truth and
everybody else is lying and same things
happening in Russia Russia is actually
weathering this storm quite well right
now and everybody who says well Putin's
lying well yes if that's your response
the you know them then why did we do
what we did as a country why did we
outsource all of our you know supply for
medical and beyond our food system etc
our waste system to China if we if we're
that distrustful of them if they're that
incompetent if and why did we outsource
our space program to Russia if they're
always lying and incompetent in law it's
just not true
these countries have incredible assets
attributes you know truths that are not
familiar to us in a lot of ways and
therefore we doubt them and we are
suspicious of them we should always
question the data we should always ask
you know are we are we seeing the
objective data and oftentimes we're not
but I would say that the likelihood of
us same truth and objectiveness from US
media more so than Russia or China is no
longer the case maybe there was some
cold and age and American journalism
that that was the case but we all have
to know that our media is fully bought
and paid for
just as our politicians are fully bought
and paid for over and over again and so
I don't understand why we why we
collapse away from the opportunity of
that singularity you subscribe there I
think we have the opportunity to do that
and I think there's large sectors of our
population that are doing that and all
ready to rise and are ready to say we
are one and I see that so true in your
audience rich you've inspired people
that's why they tune in over and over
again to your show is because they they
feel the gravity of truth the gravity of
real experience being shared and viewed
and difficult questions being asked on
your show all the time and we are hungry
for that truth we're hungry for that and
so I know that societies were rising and
so I think that's my optimism is that
the people are rising however we're rise
against a mechanistic system that has
become extremely powerful that's
suppressing the common you know
sentiment or the common vibration and
replacing it with fear and domination
and the fact that we since 9/11 have
gotten very used to our civil liberties
being taken away from us in in
justification for safety is interesting
I know is it wrong for us to be
sequester wait no I think we I think
it's totally appropriate first to take
the appropriate public measures to
reduce the speed at which this virus is
going to travel through our system and
and we should not be mistaken this virus
is all over the world it's going to
continue to infect every vulnerable and
person out there it will just go slower
you know as we do this like we can't
stay sequestered in our houses for the
next two years and the last coronavirus
that hit us I don't know if people
remember but we already saw a global
coronavirus scare with with SARS back in
2001 2003 and that went out way after
two years and the scientists people
still don't understand why it went away
it doesn't make sense that it did but it
did which we can get into laters like
where are these chrono viruses coming
from and why but but you know two years
is too long for us to hide away and stay
away from work and everything else so
we're gonna get back in the game and
where all of our immune systems are
going to be challenged with this virus
and some of us will get sick and some of
us we get severe severely ill and some
of us will will die and in the meantime
you know where do we where do we stay
lucid where do we stay aware of civil
liberties and so I think that that
balance is going to be you know
extremely tricky just as it was in the
wake of 9/11 it was very difficult for
people to question the story that was
being put out by our media for 9/11 they
would get just trashed by everybody
politicians on down to the man on the
street and so I think we're in another
one of those situations where if you
raise your head slightly above the the
current approved journalistic message of
fear you're gonna be shot down and
that's just dangerous for us as a people
if we if we continue to tolerate that
level of suppression of questioning it
doesn't mean we're disobedient I think
that we can be very respectful and
compliant with you know the social
distancing against the quarantine and
everything else we're going to call this
stuff but we have to also be very
cognizant of personally why are you
doing that are you doing that for the
greater good and where where are you
maintaining your sense of civil
liberties in the midst of that and I
think that that civil liberties comes in
an ability for us to question while
we're being compliant and we should
really question everything all the time
when it comes to massive efforts like
her being currently being happy mm-hmm
you know we are in this post truth fake
news era and that is a breeding ground
for fear and suspicion and conspiracy a
level of distrust that I think also
foments the nationalism to which you
were speaking about and by dint of
autocratic rule you know China really
was able to marshal resources quickly
and effectively and by all accounts they
are you know on the other side of this I
know
economically they're starting to get
back to normal things are starting to
ship from there once again and we've all
seen images and videos of protocols that
they put in place at the airports etc to
effectively test people and I think that
part of what's informing the fear
response here is we don't know who to
trust or what's true and what's not true
what we do know is there aren't enough
tests the tests aren't accessible so the
numbers are probably higher than what we
suspect because of that and also it's
illustrating the fragility of our
systems like
when one cog suddenly breaks the whole
system of global infrastructure quickly
begins to become dismantled and I think
that also breeds fear when people look
at the economic landscape of what's
happening now and what is surely to come
the domino impact long-term of the
stoppage and the slowdown that we're
experiencing right now so I'm empathetic
to the fear response because on some
level that's a very human response and
it is frightening right now for people
to be feeling vulnerable about their
personal health and also about the
prospect of how they're gonna sort of
make their way in the world once the you
know sort of initial threat of this
begins to lift and we have to kind of
reckon with the economic wreckage and
how to put that back together so I think
it would be helpful for people to kind
of provide a little perspective or
guidance on the opportunity aspect of
this for those that are sequestered
right now and are trying to figure out
how to make productive use of this
moment of isolation awesome yeah yeah
there's a lot there then the opportunity
has never been bigger yeah I really feel
extremely excited about that and the
opportunities are multifaceted here you
know on the topic of supply chains and
everything else that you just described
the United States needs to wake up to
what it's done in the mission of making
more money we created Chinese supply
lines for our hospitals and for many
facets of our economy to make more money
we exploited cheap Chinese labor and
efficient and intelligent you know
production systems that the Chinese have
put into place over the years we
exploited that so that our companies can
make more money now hospitals are like
why don't we have masks it's because you
wanted to pay half a cent or one cent
less for each mask that you were going
to buy so you outsource that to try
and the companies in the US that used to
make those masks went out of business
and so hey you know our businesses and
their supply lines in the mission of
making more money have made us very
vulnerable as consumers we've driven
much of that we continue to be very
short-sighted and really blind to the
reality and the impact of our consumer
decisions we want the 99-cent chicken
breast we want you know the dollar forty
nine six pack of sodas you know whatever
it is we continue to want these
extremely subsidized and artificial you
know price points on our our food system
is probably the best example but it's
really every product out there from your
respirator in the ICU all the way to the
strap on your purse you know it's just
like these things got outsourced because
we wanted things to be cheaper and we
wanted more things and so the
opportunity that we have right now is to
read reevaluate that of like what do you
actually want do you actually want a
99-cent chicken breast or would you like
health do you want that hospital system
to be the biggest economy in the US or
would you like to see our farmers regain
the you know the status of the largest
economy on the planet because just you
know we are our food system is like 1.2
trillion dollars a year our medical
system is is three point seven trillion
dollars a year and so we're three times
out spending our food with just the cost
of chronic disease who cares what what
do we want do we want cheap food or do
we want good health and so the
opportunity here is as we sit at home
with our loved ones let's start
reevaluating our supply chain and in the
household how do you start to reclaim
autonomy and it's super cheap and
awesome to do it some simple things are
buy a cabbage or even better start to
grow a cabbage we have spring coming on
which means the end of flu season the
end of crota buyer season is going to be
here just down to the nature of the
northern hemisphere going into warmer
weather is going to be good for
everything but we're about to see spring
hit and so as Springs
then right now this week sit down with
your kids your family and start mapping
out the garden that you never planted
before or and start with a couple of
containers if it's intimidating to do
anything else or you don't the space
start with a couple containing plants
and put them on your porch or put them
on in your window and let's start
growing stuff again and that's where
this shift is going to begin is where is
your supply line do you know it if
you're not going to grow your food then
start to know your farmers our work with
farmers footprint the last couple years
has just been you know so sobering to
see how devastated our are in our
national you know food system is and
nowhere is that devastation felt
stronger than the farmers themselves
that are losing you know six thousand
eight thousand family farms a year now
and suicide rates have never been so
high at the dairy industry is an
interesting one for you and I that are
plant-based fanatics it's you know we
were part of this movement of changing
demand but then in the bottom fell out
of the dairy industry the last year as
we went into these trade wars with China
and everything else we the the bottom
dropped out and the American dairy co-op
which is the largest coop of dairy
farmers in the country you know the milk
gets shipped to their distribution
centers and then they send back checks
to the farmers and those checks got so
small this past year and a half that
they started the practice of sending out
suicide hotlines with every single
paycheck because farmers are killing
themselves at unprecedented rates as as
they the crisis really hits them full
force and so we need to know those
farmers again we need to reconnect and
tell them what we want which is we want
real food and we want really healthy
food and so if there's no dairy industry
demand we're gonna help you make the
transition to to the making oat milk or
making whatever it is that is in demand
you know and we would like to actually
see some real fruits and vegetables and
unprocessed foods coming into every
state again we stopped growing food in
the United States you if you think we
have a serious crisis on you know our
hospitals right now wait until our food
system
disrupted it's one thing when you don't
have you know hospital mass to take your
other critically ill it's another thing
when literally every single household
doesn't have food and that's the
scenario we've set ourselves up for in
the United States and Kansas which is
our most agricultural state in the
country 90% of the acreage in Kansas is
agricultural II managed and they import
90 percent of their food as a state and
one in four children in Kansas is going
hungry for lack of calories today and so
when we started this chemical farming
mission in the last thirty years the
whole mission was to feed the world and
we wake up thirty years later to find
out no we just made multi mega
billion-dollar corporations much richer
through buying all their chemicals but
we completely lost our autonomy to feed
ourselves let alone the world in that
process the world is feeding us today
and the supply chain is you know tenuous
and the reservoirs are low and so you
know every city is now an island it
cannot produce its own you know it you
know electricity let alone its own you
know food system so it's time to start
taking that back again and you know my
wife and I in and one of our friends and
son quarantine with us from coming back
from travels sat around last night and
there was candlelight sitting here
burning in the living room lights were
off and I was you know kind of getting
myself into a space where I could talk
coherently I hope today and in that
process was just so peaceful there's
just a sense of like man I don't need
the lights on I've got a candle I've you
know need to grow some plants on the
back porch we need to yeah it's so
simple the moves we need to make to
completely change the vulnerability that
we have at a health level at a food
supply level at a healthcare crisis
level we need to take these steps at the
individual level and the whole system
will change around us very rapidly and
I'm very excited for you know
our companies to have to to change with
us
I am excited that the dairy industry is
being called the change I'm sad that the
American government is continues to
subsidize claps rather than foster
change but nonetheless I think you know
if we connect with those farmers they're
going to show us the path if we connect
with em you know the the energy sector
on a more personal level instead of just
flipping on our lights start to really
think about what is energy and where's
come from what does it mean to live in
an air-conditioned space 24/7 where the
temperature is always 72 degrees 275
degrees no matter what time of year what
does that mean for my health is it
actually good for me to have windows
closed and and heating and air
conditioning on year-round and the
answer of course is well no it's you're
completely isolated away from nature
there and so what does nature start to
look like in your daily life again and
we have this awesome opportunity right
now to do that and yeah I was excited
when San Francisco asked their
population to voluntarily restrict their
activities and restrict themselves to
the homes or parks and national parks
trails nature areas so I thought that
was brilliant for San Francisco to say
stay away from each other
to reduce the spread of this virus but
get out in nature whenever possible and
you know that needs to be our mindset so
take a look at your your request from
your local governments and see if
they're saying that you can't go outside
at all which is really not happening
anywhere they're basically saying stay
out of public places stay away from one
another and let's see where it goes and
if it gets more dogmatic than that then
we should raise concern to our public
officials and say look it's really
important for the health of our children
that they're outside and if we just put
them inside for the next you know three
months or whatever is being demanded
their health is gonna really be
undermined and we're gonna see younger
and younger people yes you know coming
under the the effects of this virus if
we if we make ourselves unhealthy in the
mission of isolation human isolation is
a horrible thing and it's been you know
maybe the silver lining of the social
media world is that people are really
reconnecting in a million in unique ways
and I'm a little bit disturbed by just
the amount of human effort being put
into creating clever memes right now but
if that's what we need to do this data
connector maybe that's not vibration
we're in but I hope that you know as you
get bored of making memes you start to
really turn your attention towards these
bigger opportunities that the time is
providing you is sit down with your
loved ones whether that's you know by
Xion my sister just implemented the
clever thing that our family has never
done before she just implemented a
Sunday afternoon family zoom conference
and so me and my three siblings and
everything else get the opportunity now
to start to engage in a way that we
usually don't think to like we go about
our busy lives and connect every couple
months but now we can connect every week
and spend time really talking about
what's important to us as a family so
think about how you're gonna reconnect
your family in a more deep way than just
a text message or a meme or something
and let's let's really start to talk
about what's important I mean I think
that there is a interesting
recalibration that is taking place with
this sequestration that's compelling us
to take inventory of our daily habits
and to get clarity on what's truly
important versus extraneous and with
that I'm seeing an increase in the level
of social connectivity in my own
personal life and just observational II
with other people your example of the
zoom call is you know perfectly
encapsulates that like people are
discovering zoom and despite our
geographic separation I'm seeing a more
coherent social conversation happening
right now there is a unification
occurring because of the fact that this
is impacting all of us in such a
unprecedented way and there is something
beautiful about that and my hope is that
you know a wonderful flower will come
out of that that will precipitate a
change in in you know the systems that
cohere to create the scenario that we
find ourselves in right now I will say
also that
probably not aware of this because
you're in a Wahoo but San Francisco and
also Los Angeles just closed their parks
today so that's no longer the case
although I would say you know I have
trails as you know that surround my
house and that's really where I'm
finding peace every day being able to go
out and trail run or get out on my bike
and generally when I'm out on the trails
I might see one or two or three other
people but recently it's been the most
socially congested aspect of my day so
many people are getting outside and
going on these family walks so much so
that you have to kind of you know take a
wide berth around them when you're
running to maintain that social distance
but it's been interesting there's a you
know I suppose a there's there's a great
positivity in that and that people for
the first time ever it was like a logjam
of cars parked in the little parking lot
at the trailhead that I go to typically
and I've never seen that before so
that's a great thing my hope is that
despite parks being closed that people
will still find ways to get outside I
think that's crucial in this moment
right now but I think to your point of
the food supply being imperiled by
what's happening you know in Los Angeles
when you go to the grocery store they're
only allowing people in a few at a time
to make sure that there's no
overcrowding in the grocery stores and
there's plenty of
aisles where the shelves are bare and my
sense is that you know restocking is
coming and we're not in any imminent
threat of our food supply being
imperiled to the extent that we're not
going to be able to eat but it doesn't
take much imagination to understand and
realize that we're a hair's breadth away
from that actually becoming a reality
and when you grasp the fact that the
food that we produce in this country is
going towards animal agriculture or it's
getting exported overseas or being used
to create ethanol for processed food and
snacks and all yeah or fuel or things
like that you realize once again it goes
back to the fragility of our systems
we're not in a situation in which were
robust enough
to weather a crisis like that again the
wake-up call and and the conversation
that needs to happen is how do we create
robustness in our food system in our
energy supply in in our you know sort of
popular unity in our in our kind of
commercial consciousness that drives
markets to you know create the systems
that we need and deserve to basically
you know survive as a species while also
maintaining the integrity of the planet
sustainability I guess is what I'm
getting at I think that's you know you
know very well said and I think we need
to be coming to terms of the fact that
whatever fear and anger we have around
this virus and all this if we keep
projecting that at the virus we're not
gonna realize that what we're really
afraid of is that our system is collapse
and our vulnerabilities are profound and
get worse every day
and so we need to fundamentally change
all that and we so easily can and again
it I really think it begins the food
like you know the healthcare system will
right itself as soon as we fix the food
system and so the regenerative effort
that we have a farmer's footprint has
been interesting because the ripple
effects are not what I expected when I
set out to make that documentary film I
didn't even set out to make a non-profit
initially because I didn't you know that
the problem was so big I was just set
out to tell a story of how damaging
roundup was to ecology of the rivers and
ocean system and how is affecting human
health along those water systems and
then as soon as we got on our first farm
we realized oh my gosh there is a crisis
and a vulnerability here that goes far
beyond you know the poisoning of our
water systems it's it's the poisoning of
the minds of humanity here and going on
and and so the story changed and as soon
as we started watching regenerative soil
management practices coming on these
farms it was again the unexpected
happened it wasn't that oh great the
fuze healthier and the nutrients are
denser in the food that's again the
story I thought I was going to tell all
that happens but it pales in comparison
to the human journey in there
these farmers wake up with such you know
optimism suddenly that that's been
missing for generations and they like I
can I can be an independent autonomous
farmer and I can make money again and my
farm can make money and my kids are
coming back to the farm because they're
seeing success and they want to be a
part of that and you know now there's a
you know a plan for me bill pass off
this farm did my children and it's
working and like the the joy just
eclipses even the economic or everything
else human joy is just the most powerful
of things that I've ever seen
I just am amazed by it when when you
have true joy in your being
it changes you become this this radical
force you you become this this entity
that just is so much larger than your
body at that point and you you can
change everything most of all your
mindset and and your your vibration and
when you put yourself in a really high
vibration state good stuff comes it's
it's just so obvious when you put
yourself in a high vibration state you
could experience success and joy and
human impact on levels of the current
status of society isn't ready to let you
know you can do if you just embody that
joy at a level and then surrender your
expectations on what what's going to
come out of that and the joy is
engendered not by big things but it's
engendered in the tiny little things
it's in the candle light with your your
lover that you've called your wife for
years or your your children or your you
know new girlfriend or whatever it is
that's in your space right now that
small human touch that small human
experience of being sequestered away for
a moment and light those candles look
into each other's eyes and and just
express your gratitude to one another
for being alive right now because the
reality is we are just the tip of
biology on their earth the microbiome
was always for life it's never against
life if it appears that the microbiome
is threatened
yes sir killing us it's because we have
misaligned ourselves with nature at a
large level and we need to realign
ourselves with that and we need to start
to to think about what what it looks
like to be within our moment living in
as light beings at a high vibration in
his face and time with high
consciousness with respect for human
life with a respect for animal life
that's not happening on the planet
people are right now is you know saying
again Oh China makes this happen every
year because they have all these animal
markets and food markets and everything
else and the reality is yes that
actually is a problem when we're killing
sixty billion animals a year for human
consumption that's a global problem and
that's not a Chinese problem that is a
global problem that we're killing sixty
billion animals but a bigger problem
that those sixty billion animals are
largely being held in captivity in these
extreme toxic you know inhumane you know
levels of management and so if we see
viruses coming out of that well that's
the microbiomes check on the reality
that we live in there are checks and
balances and biology certainly that work
better than the checks and balances in
our government and and life is gonna
have to read to be redirected if we
oppose you know health and an ecology on
that level really what you're getting at
is developing a healthy dose of humility
and the recursive theme and everything
that you've been talking about comes
back to having in there being like
equanimity in terms of our relationship
to the planet whether it's our food
systems whether it's you know how we
interact with each other we are out of
whack and it's Nature's Way of reminding
us that we need to reset and pay
attention and again I keep saying this
but you know I don't want to minimize
what's happening there are a lot of
people who are scared and there are many
people who are suffering and people are
dying but I think you know if we can
really connect with this humility we
have an opportunity to embrace the
opportunity to return with a more sort
of synergistic relationship with our
planet I mean farmers footprint is a
perfect example of
by returning to what is natural and
cyclical with the planet these farmers
have been able to find new life and with
that you know a new happiness and a new
lifeline for their families and the
domino effect of that is is profound and
if we can extrapolate on that example to
reflect back upon our own relationship
to the planet and our behaviors and our
consumer choices I think it can be
highly instructive going forward at the
same time many of these things that
we're talking about involve systems that
are out of the control of the average
consumer how much impact can I really
have you know our global supply chain on
our food system on policy on economics
on you know what Big Pharma decides to
do etc but what we can do is seize this
moment of solitude and sequestration to
really inventory and reflect on our own
behavior patterns because the ecosystem
that resides within each of us is just a
microcosm of the macrocosm that we're
experiencing externally right now and
for me I've been kind of thinking about
this in terms of you know through that
lens like how am i living what in my
life is not in balance where can I live
more in alignment with nature's cyclical
rhythms where can I you know find more
balance in my day-to-day routine and
where am I blind or in denial about
things that I'm doing that are
perpetrating a problem that recur zin my
own life and I think the more that we
can all adopt that practice I think we
all kind of emerge out of this assuming
that we can emerge out of it healthy
more empowered and stronger and more
capable and humble and in a better
position to create that world that we
all can imagine for ourselves and yet
seem so out of grasp the moment
yeah I think I think there is a danger
of a sense of hopelessness or
helplessness on the level of the one but
I want to again bring it back to maybe
just you know one one small family farm
in Minnesota that you can you know that
farmers footprint 20 minute documentary
was you know feature this one family and
watching Grant and Dawn on their journey
of self empowerment was you know
profound to see what this one little
family decided to do and the speed at
which new community came to them when
they were had been completely ostracized
and lonely because they had you know
made the decision in the middle of
Minnesota to go into some sort of
organic process or something like that
as soon as they kicked the the common
paradigm they were literally ostracized
socially and everything else and so they
were in one of the deepest states of
loneliness and isolation and depression
that you could put a family in and then
with just the simple decision to take
care of Mother Earth under their feet
and say we're gonna do the right thing
for this 300 acres and it's not our
responsibility to figure out to do with
the other 125 million acres and the
United States we're just gonna take care
of this little 300 acres and as soon as
they did that they found new community
around the world that had been you know
taking care of soil for decades and had
new you know insights and resources and
information experience to share with
them and they now find themselves you
know embraced by a global community and
you know their kids coming back to the
farm and you know the the layers are so
good and all they had to do was the
right thing at the small level and you
know now we see their story impacting an
entire world of farmers I just came out
of Australia because we were launching a
parallel program to farmers footprint in
Australia in the next couple of months
and you know just to watch the impact
that that film has had here these you
know farmers who've never been to
Australia probably and everything else
and yet they're impacting every
sector of Agriculture all over the world
because they did the right thing on the
small scale and so that's what you can
do with your family at the end of World
War two we were growing 45% of our food
in our backyard gardens 45% of our food
now we grow less than 0.1% of our food
in our backyard gardens you can be so
powerful in growin tree growing that
garden one of my favorite success story
is my clinic when I set it up back in
2010 was in one of the most impoverished
areas of Virginia fifth-generation
poverty no grocery stores in that County
people were eating out of gas stations
as their primary food source most days
and it was you know the ultimate food
desert penultimate processed food
nightmare and I went in with my clinic
to teach plant-based diet and to help
people you know consider to regain their
health and what I found out was it was
not just their health that was yeah the
opportunity shift it was actually their
sense of autonomy and their sense of
Independence that they've been lacking
for perhaps generations and the way that
they did that was through planting a
garden and as soon as they planted a
garden and found out they could produce
their own food and that the immediate
consequences of that was a reduction in
their medication costs and co-pays for
hospital visits it was just like this
unbridled sense of capacity one of the
african-american pastors that was coming
to my group he was fantastic reverend
within the black baptist community in my
area and he got a hold of the message
that if he regrew his garden he could
really have an impact on his own health
here he wasn't as late 70s when he came
to my clinic and stage heart disease and
diabetes all the typical stuff and he
you know heard this and remembered that
his grandmother had the largest garden
in the entire community and so he
replanted this this four acre garden
with three generations of his kids and
grandkids and great-grandkids and within
two years he was feeding over 40
families out of their their garden and
yeah it's just like you just can't
underestimate the power of doing the
right thing in your backyard on your
porch in your window do the right thing
just at the tiny level and again this
raises your
operation and bigger stuff will come
keep surrender the expectations of what
its gonna look like and just do the
right thing and and you're gonna enjoy
it one of the coolest things that you
could do with your kids right now it's
not a great time for you to be growing
perhaps and takes a little time to get a
crop in the ground or plant in the
ground so to start with this start with
a salt water and a cabbage and get your
kids involved or get your grandkids
involved or whoever you you're not
sequestered away from right now and make
a saltwater brine chop up the cabbage
drop it in the saltwater open it up to
the microbiome of the air and let the
bacteria and fungi at millions of
species potential come floating into
that crock over the next day or two with
just a towel over it and then you know
after a couple days out you can then
decide to char that or whatever you want
or you can just leave it in the crock
and keep swiping the top every day and
to keep the water clean and over the
next two weeks you'll create one of the
most amazing sauerkraut experiences
you've ever had and you can just let it
keep going and take a bite every couple
days and and experience yourself what
the microbiome is doing to that food and
it will taste different every couple
days and that experiment will cost you
maybe a buck and a half and it will
totally change your perspective on your
food system because right now you're
spending 12 bucks for a little few
ounces of sauerkraut that's vacuum
packed in plastic and multiple levels
chemical in you're paying 12 bucks to do
that and you can for a dollar fifty make
it huge untainted crock of sauerkraut
this is where autonomy actually comes
from is just this journey and you know
your your wife is doing such an amazing
job with her cheese company right now
because she's doing the right thing
she's saying let's let's just ferment
non-dairy and turn that into delicious
food and it will change our family it
will change our community as they
realize this is in our grasp we can
actually create artists and food in our
kitchens we can create artisan food you
know in our backyards and this is where
you guys became so successful in your
plant-based movement is
bringing autonomy back into the
household to be creative in the kitchen
again the colors that are in your
cookbooks are just such a joy and it's
it's a sense of you know beauty to the
whole thing and also money if we're here
for anything it's to to experience
beauty and to recognize it and shout it
from the rooftops when we see it and to
celebrate it and if you just do that in
your day to day if you dig into beauty
and you start making sure that
everything you do is ground it back to a
pursuit of beauty and you're gonna find
a different life and you will you know
save the American people from collapse
in the process and you will show the
world that we can build a nation that's
not about empires and sequestration of
power and wealth and resources were
about create co-creation I think that's
one of the shining lights of the
American people as we are a family
creative group because we've been
empowered at the self level the Chinese
people are not empowered to be
individualistic in their pursuits but
they come to America to participate in
that and they come to to dig into a city
like San Francisco or Chicago or New
York for the opportunity to pursue
creativity and beauty on their own terms
and so let's be that again let's let's
be the Ellis Island of the world again
and we can do that if we stop trying to
take everything from everybody and make
them do all our work and we can start
doing it by just being a co creative
society again connecting humans to be Co
creative rather than consumptive and
with the world is our oyster it it can
all open up to bring more beauty into
our lives the pearls that are there
waiting for us to see are the other
cultures there's such beauty in the
Fijian people there's such beauty in the
Filipino people there's such beauty in
the faces of Honduras and El Salvador
and Peru and you know in South Africa
and
you know we are missing the beauty for
what what it was is what is distracting
us it's our social media it's our
Instagram page and everything else so
it's it's our 10,000 selfies you know
like if we stop looking at our own face
and go to see ourselves within the faces
of everybody else we'll see a much more
beautiful picture of ourselves and it
begins of a sauerkraut I'm listening to
you
eloquently deliver this beautiful speech
and all I'm doing is thinking about how
I haven't been able to get it together
to grow a garden at our house I'm
listening
because Julie and I always revert to the
excuse that we're so busy and you know
in in in hearing you you know it really
is about the the simplicity of all of it
and and also you know connecting with
your neighbors it's not about the global
economy as much as it is about your
local community that's right yeah and
you know I think that the American mind
is quick to find failure and then use
you know multiple excuses in our failure
and and so I think it's because we we
have such rigid belief systems about
what a garden should be it should have
tomato and basil and eggplant and
cucumbers and squash from peppers and
bla bla bla and if we don't get the time
to do that and we don't do that then
we're like well we've been intending
that for years and then we hold that
against ourselves and I've started
opening up my own definition of garden
so that I stops seeing myself as a
failure here and our property in
Virginia we have you know six acres of
beautiful woods that have really been
untouched by chemical agriculture for
its entire history and so it's just like
it feels like this natural treasure
whenever I'm in that space we have like
ancient you know ground covers growing
in the woods that date back you know 50
to 100 million years in the fossil
record and so we have like this
incredible thing and then I chipped out
this this garden this little quarter
acre garden over the last 10 years and I
never have that thing in good repair but
growing in that is an extraordinary
amount of wildflowers now that have self
seeded and found their way in there and
when I go out there in this
time now the amount of butterflies
caterpillars birds are just berserk
it's like every single millimeter that
that garden is crawling with life and so
I've expanded my my concepts for my own
psyche in some ways but also to expand
past the concept of the tomato plant to
realize you know what Mother Nature
doesn't need more communal plants mother
nature neatness biodiversity and so in
your backyard you could just start a
butterfly garden and let the butterflies
bring life in and you know the moths at
night bringing life in there and be
there these pollinators are going
extinct at extreme rates and really are
you know our harbinger of the extinction
of life as we know it on the planet and
so you may not need to feed just you you
might be able to expand your ideas to
feed Mother Earth again in her
biodiversity and nature in her
biodiversity and so growing in my garden
right now is Jerusalem artichokes which
grow in the ground they're kind of like
a potato but this literally looks like
tiny little sunflowers at the top these
tall stalks and in the middle the summer
and they're beautiful to look at and
then they always flop over and kind of
ugly I think in the fall but then I
realized that that biomass that's now
flopped over on the ground is now
protecting my soil and it's creating all
these microclimates for earthworms and
everything else in the meat there and
then you get to dig up the Jerusalem
artichokes and literally these things
are will take over large amounts of
space plant one little tuber of
Jerusalem artichoke and you're gonna end
up with you know a massive patch in a
few years so my garden totally
unattended everything else has this
biomass in this food source that now
covers you know 15 square feet or
something of these incredible things and
you pull these sunflowers out of the
ground and on their root systems or
dozens of these little potato like
nuggets and those Jerusalem artichokes
also called sunchokes
are some of the most delicious food I've
ever eaten so I would just encourage
everybody listening to thank you know
beyond just the little manicured
cucumber tomato patch to think about how
do you create biodiversity out there and
let it be messy because nature is messy
she loves
you know the kindergarten approach to
life which is you know the
finger-painting and colors everywhere
and no particular you know order except
that in its disorder we realize a beauty
that could have never been done in any
form of symmetry or or
careful planning so so be raucous in
your gardening let it go wild if you
need to and if if it quote-unquote fails
because you get too busy because your
time is demanded by all the good things
you're doing for the world that's okay
let it do its thing as well and let it
realize its full potential as it would
plan it not as you would plan it and
let's not think of that as a failure I
like that it feels like it gives me
permission to begin because I do have in
my mind like what it's supposed to look
like and to me it's very intimidating
and I start to think about all the time
it's gonna require but the idea of just
starting with one thing and being more
in the allowing process and not beating
yourself up I feel like that is a good
like motivator for me to finally get
over myself and commence that process so
thanks for that I think it would be good
to share with people a few things that
they can do to buttress their microbiome
in the meantime and and you know boost
their immunity as much as possible other
than you know look the social distancing
or the physical distancing that getting
a lot of sleep you know staying hydrated
you know washing your hands all the
things that you're gonna hear time and
time again what are some perhaps less
intuitive things that people could be
doing to make sure that they're taking
care of themselves to the best extent
possible yeah it's critical first and to
think about this it's an extension of
the garden we just talked about really
and so the data coming out of China
again in this great paper that just was
released last week is intriguing that
they're finding that the unifying you
know risk of fatality from this virus is
not the virus itself it's the
vulnerability that comes in the
pneumonias and other conditions that
come after the viruses and infects you
and so they're unifying future that
they're finding in the
is this dysbiosis there which is a terms
to describe an unbalanced microbiome in
the gut and so if you haven't been up on
the last ten years of medical science
every single condition on the planet has
now been tied back to the microbiome is
that's the that's the nutshell of the
last ten years of global science and
it's obvious in the end that what would
grow a healthy tomato plant is gonna be
what's gonna grow a healthy human
there's no way that biology can't be
founded in the microbiome because it's
literally where all of the nutrients and
the fuel production and ultimately the
communication for sell sell and
trans-species communications come from
and so to prepare yourself for a
resilience in this time as you know and
again
if you don't continue these things
thereafter we're gonna see something
much worse than than our current
coronavirus situation so this again is a
template for long term life not just
what you're going to do for the next few
weeks while you're thinking about it so
how do you start to build this into your
life and this is literally what my
companies have been doing since since
our origin in 2010 so for the last
decade I've been steeped in this mindset
of what is nutrition how is it found in
the microbiome what is the microbiome
how is human biology founded in it and
so what we've discovered over the years
is that a couple of really important
aspects have gone missing from our daily
experience and a lot of it has to do
with carbon which is interesting because
carbon is actually the backbone of
biology and to become a doctor or
microbiologists or anything in the
health sciences you have to to take
organic chemistry and the word organic
chemistry means carbon chemistry the
word organic refers to you life built on
carbon structure and so it may seem very
foreign to you at the moment but I want
you to start to re-envision life on
earth as a series of carbon molecules
that being the case you need to start to
think about carbon is the most important
thing that you can do for yourself and
carbon and the human experience is the
nutrients that we consume and so sugar
is a large carbohydrate string of of
carbon molecules
and so it can come in the form of
glucose fructose galactose all these
different you know carbon chains and
then they get cleaved down to just the
same a little carbon molecule of co2 in
the end fatty acids are the other form
of fuel there's only two forms of fuel
for cellular biology as we know it the
multicellular organisms reformed Oh
earthworm to human it has to do with the
carbon chains of carbohydrates and the
carbon chains of fatty acids and all
these diets that fight over should you
be a high carb low carb high fat low fat
all that the mitochondria just sit here
and laugh at us I think because they're
the same thing they're they're carbon
strings that as soon as they go into a
mitochondria which is the only thing
that can use either one is going to
cleave that down to release energy as it
Cleaves those carbon chains and release
co2 and so the mitochondria are going to
do the exact same thing in fact a fatty
acid and a glucose molecule become the
exact same molecule acetyl co a in an a2
enzyme step for to enter the
mitochondria it goes to a so co a and so
in a single mon step actually goes the
same molecule so glucose fat single
enzyme turns in an acyl co a second
enzyme acetyl co a sudoko a becomes the
entire you know energy source and in
producing the energy that would then
produce co2 it releases electrons and
the electrons become our communication
system and so that's where we've been
focused as a company is understanding
how do bacteria take the carbon turn it
into bioactive agents and communicate
through that system to engender health
longevity regeneration all of these
things that are so fascinating and so in
the nutshell what you can start to do is
look for the most clean sources of
complex carbohydrates and fatty acids
that you can put your hands on and so
that's gonna again come down to the
garden so seeds nuts and legumes or your
fantastic sources of fatty acids your
complex carbohydrates are easy in that
it's anything with with beautiful color
and it basically on the plate and so
it's your your vegetables your fruit but
also think you know under the ground as
an important one so that your root
vegetables are really rich and these
carbon sources in their skin
particulars so the skin of a carrot the
skin of a potato these have basically
the entire periodic chart but they're
awesome very rich in these these soil
carbon compounds and so think root
vegetables as a source because not only
do they have that micronutrient and
carbon density they also have this very
important aspect of fiber and fiber in
your diet is really the building block
for micro ecosystems within your gut and
the fiber supports diversity of
microbial species and the the microbes
that are missing from the guts of the
Chinese people that are dying from
coronavirus in this paper last week are
the very bacteria that go missing when
you eliminate fiber from your diet and
so I'm intrigued by the paper because
it's basically it's pointing to what
we've seen over and over again through
all human diseases if you eliminate
fiber from your diet you start to suffer
if you eliminate complex carbohydrates
from your diet your microbiome shifts
and it shifts to a fermentation rather
than anaerobic digestion and the
fermentation the firm acute bacteria are
very closely linked to this chronic
inflammatory state of the gut and immune
system and so it's very exciting when I
see that paper because the first thing
that we can do is get people eating from
the ground as fast as possible so let's
get you know our plant-based diets
revved up let's go to the root
vegetables we're looking at sweet
potatoes we're looking at your radishes
the daikon radish is a super interesting
one there that doesn't get recognized
much but your red radishes your black
radishes your the white radish of the
daikon looks like a giant carrot your
carrots themselves the heirloom carrots
the purple and the white and the the
orange carrots and leave the skins on
these things for goodness sakes we just
go and skin these things immediately and
then just eat the starch out of the
middle
but potato leave the skins on and get
the whole experience here of the
complexity that you need and so that's
where it begins the other thing that
then is lacking after all that is in the
current human experience is the
microbiome itself and so this is a
little bit more complicated because it
takes a little bit more effort on your
part than just putting the right
vegetables on your plate
but what's been missing increasingly
because of our antibiotic environment is
the carbon communication network of the
microbiome and so now that we were you
know in the u.s. we put about
thirty-eight million pounds of
antibiotics into our animal feed a year
we put about eight million pounds of
antibiotic into our humans through
physician offices and prescriptions and
then we put 300 million pounds of
antibiotic in the form of roundup and
glyphosate into our soils and water
systems every year through chemical
farming the the scale of that antibiotic
is really you know multiplied by the
fact that the chemical of glyphosate and
roundup is water-based and seven now
ends up in the air we breathe 75 percent
of the air we breathe in any
agricultural state is contaminated up 75
percent of the rainfall in our
agriculture states orchid animator's
roundup and when I say agricultural
state that's most of them aren't that's
one of the main economies of any state
and so we're all breathing and being
rained on and eating and drinking these
antibiotics and so what's happened is
we've lost biodiversity in the gut and
with that we've become very vulnerable
in many many ways and the primary thing
that we've been working on this as a
science group in our laboratories for
the last eight years is to understand
how did the soils you know do this
historically and how can the anxious
soil give this back to us so for the
last decade and we've been working on
the nutrition side but in for the last
eight years we've been working on the
soil secrets and we've been extracting
for the last you know eight years
these small carbon molecules that act as
the communication networks that can
exchange electrons once they're
activated with with oxygen and hydrogen
you can exchange electrons which means
you can create communication between
cells importantly between species and so
we've been extracting that that product
is now called ion biome and so my
company produces that so this is the
most biased part of this entire podcast
and take this with a grain of salt if
you want but for the last eight years
we've been showing that when you you
take these carbon molecules and get
oxygen hydrogen buying them again in our
production center and then put that into
a bottle and then give that to a human
something amazing happens it's it gives
me goosebumps every time somebody is
about to put this in their mouth because
humans have only been around 200,000
years and the the molecular intelligence
the biodiversity that we're tapping into
is actually 60 million years old so
we're taking soil that's 60 million
years old has been compressed into an
aura called leonardite and then we
extract the carbon molecules small
carbon molecules and then we make oxygen
hydrogen behind those carbon molecules
again so that they become nonreactive
and non inflammatory and then we put
that into a human system and suddenly
you have a you know billions of billions
of versions of these little carbon
snowflakes each species of bacteria and
fungi from 60 million years ago sending
their own little signal their own
message of intelligence into this system
and you put a human species it's only
two hundred thousand years old into this
level of intelligence and what happens
under the microscope is mind-blowing
because it's never been seen you see
fundamental healing repair and and
three-dimensional structures coming back
into rapid function that doesn't happen
in Petri dishes petri dishes are where
we study disease in class because we
can't study health and healing because
that usually takes complex you know
systems of biology an intact immune
system it takes you know messaging from
distant you know Cellular's types in the
human biology to make healing happen it
started happening in a petri dish in
2013 with our first studies and it blew
our minds because it wasn't supposed to
happen you aren't supposed to get
healing in a human cell system in a
petri dish isolated and the answer
that's come out over the last seven
years as exciting is we keep thinking a
human biology is human human biology is
based in the microbiome itself the
biology itself and so it's extraordinary
to realize that if you put back in the
communication network of bacteria and
fungi human cells know how to repair
themselves know how to start building
cooperative three-dimensional structures
with one another it's not a sterile
petri dish anymore there's no bacteria
and fungi in there because we it is a
sterile liquid that we extract but the
communication of that vast ecosystem is
intact and in firing and when the cell
has unfettered access to information it
always goes into a regenerative state
and I think that's a lesson for life
right there biology at its foundation is
grace grace in my mind is is you know
extending the opportunity for healing
faster than the damage happens and so
biologic grace is realized here as we
see biologic systems collapse under the
pressure of decades of roundup and then
you put back communication network and
in a matter of not years or decades but
in a matter of minutes you start to see
this regenerative capacity come out of
the human gut and and the way in which
that happens is the human gut starts to
cooperate as a single organism again a
human biology is really begins of this
inside outside understanding of an
intact gut your gut lining is to test
quarts in surface area and when you
consume roundup it destroys that
structure interestingly alcohol also
does that and so if you drink it
excessive amounts alcohol will also do
the roundup injury of destroying the
tight junctions and you get a breakdown
in this this primary barrier between you
and the outside world and so with that
collapse you know of that system we lose
self identity at the biological level
and we get chronic inflammation we get
major depression we get hopelessness we
get suicide all of this from a collapse
of that gut lining when that gut lining
goes back up and the microbiome helps us
rebuild that we get to accelerate into
this journey of self identity self hope
anti-inflammatory capacity reservoirs of
resources to repair and we go into
resilience and we go into regeneration
because the microbiome is talking to us
the teachable moment there for me is the
simple truth that there is no separation
between us in the world that surrounds
us that in fact you know our microbiome
is is outward facing it is it is
technically outside of us right and the
fact that it is you know premise upon
these age-old principles that predate
humankind is not only humbling but
instructive in the sense that if we can
find a synergistic relationship with our
environments
that our complex systems of biology tend
to respond in kind to you know maintain
our health and well-being you're spot-on
and and I think I'm I'm constantly more
amazed and intrigued by the macro
consequences of that and so when we
repair this at the microscopic level we
repair this amazing boundary of the
human gut and self-identity becomes real
again for the immune system and for this
we see an immediate you know within
weeks or months we see an immediate
shift in the in the human psyche to
healthy boundaries and suddenly people
who have been in an abusive relationship
so come back to my clinic and say you
know I'd talk and just in total joy and
amazement cuz I just left my husband
who's been abusing me for 30 years and I
just finally saw my self-worth and I and
it took me years of hearing these
stories before I made the correlation of
like oh my gosh
isn't that obvious when we build our
microscopic boundaries our macroscopic
boundaries become possible again when
we're in the overwhelm of microscopic
injury and loss of self identity at the
microscopic level and we have to react
to everything outside of us suddenly
we're in you know we're sensitive to
food were senses or allergic to food
we're sensitive to the environment or
we're allergic to the environment all
these things are becoming a reality for
so many of our children one in four
children are now either allergic to
their tho air they breathe or the food
they eat and so we are losing that self
at any and when we're in that that
collapse that we get chronic
inflammation and there is no reservoir
for creative thought or sense of
self-protection in our sense of self
opportunity we're just in chaos control
damage control all the time and so to
move somebody out of that damage to
illustrate at the microscopic level
moves them into this potential at the
macroscopic level at the at the
consciousness level to become you know
have a moment to breathe to have a
moment to listen to self to see why are
you actually here what are you here to
do what is your deep soul purpose what
are you going to do with that it's
coming out of this gut intelligence and
so that's that's why we rebranded our
products everything else was
intelligence of nature became our
tagline and so ion product line was to
emphasize that
intelligence is built into the fabric of
nature and it's how nature works so well
you know right now I'm looking out at
this extreme experience of green stuff
there's palm trees bent over in the wind
right now and rain blowing by and it
it's so perfect in every shape and every
sign then there's you know all of these
cascading mountains that have been
biologically you know intact for for
millions of millions of years and the
ecosystems are bountiful you can't have
all of that beauty if if not for the the
intelligence of the system beneath it
the coordination of the beauty that we
see is communication and so as humans we
need to learn from that our
communication networks need to change
and so I'm maybe a future podcast we'll
talk about this because it's one of my
biggest passions about what we're gonna
do with the internet in the next couple
years but we need to fundamentally
change the internet to start to mimic
nature which is everything should have
unfettered access to information and if
if it does then we're gonna build beauty
we're gonna build cooperative structures
and everything else when every
interaction is exploited by a third
party for advertising and otherwise we
don't have unfettered access to
information our information is fact
warped and it's telling us only the
reality that it wants us to see and
we're not seeing the reality for what it
is and so we behave in a certain way so
we it reinforces our consumptive
behavior this is the kind of stuff that
we get excited about as a company is if
we start to mimic the communication
network that we found in the microbiome
and we start to build societies like
that that's how we're going to escape
this extinction event that we're headed
towards we can go extinct in the next 70
to 100 years on our current course or we
could literally become a different
Society we could literally become a
different species as we start to embrace
the the template that the microbiome is
revealing to us so once we get this
carbon substrate combing here and we
start to build as an infrastructure
communication within the guts of our
patients and our families we then ask
them to do the bigger thing which is now
go plug back into nature and let the
microbiome breathe
manifest in your gut and when this
carbon substrate is is rich in the gut
and the communication network is there
it allows micronesia us to quickly
develop and so you can get within just
days of supporting that carbon
communication system you can see a
bulking of the stool you can see an
increase in biodiversity within the gut
and you can see resolution of you know
long-standing imbalances that have been
present there not because the the
product is changing it's just giving
back communication and unfettered
communication leads to balance leads to
bio diversification and I think that we
need to start to mimic that across all
systems but the next step then is to do
it at the macro level just get back in
touch with nature so as soon as you put
this product in your mouth then we're
asking our patients to get outside into
environments that you don't usually go
to national parks to my knowledge
nobody's closed the national parks yet
that's probably coming next 24 hours or
something like that but yeah whatever
while the national parks are still open
think about you know hitting a national
park and if you have to wait till after
quarantine then wait until after
quarantine but the point is is you need
to go into an ecosystem you haven't
breathed recently because breathing just
like the sauerkraut that we do talked
about earlier is the result of the
microbiome air interfacing with a water
structure of a crock or whatever you're
making your sauerkraut in you are a
water structure that is calling for the
same microbiome support and interaction
and so go out and breathe and so the
hash tag breed your biome that I created
a couple years ago remains one of my our
most successful campaigns we've ever
done because people got so excited to
take pictures of their children
themselves interacting with new elements
of nature and it's just a beautiful you
know series of pictures if you scroll
through all that hashtag breathe your
biome you're gonna see you know kids and
waterfalls and you'll see you know
people on horseback out in the middle of
nowhere you'll see all kinds of just
beautiful reconnection happening and
when you do that you'll you'll get fed
by nature and you'll plug back in and
you'll have that that microscopic
experience of biodiversity and you're
gonna have the macro experience of
biodiversity because you're gonna meet
new people you're going to see new faces
you're gonna realize that humanity is
even bigger and more beautiful than you
thought just a day ago
you're gonna reengage and so ultimately
how are we going to be resilient to this
virus we're gonna eat from the ground
we're going to experience the
intelligence of the microbiome we're
going to you know really go after
nutrient density to support biologic
systems but more than that we're going
to change our environment if your health
is not at its full potential it's
because your environment has limited
your your potential and so you need to
expand your concept of of what is your
daily life and what kind of microbiome
is it
advancing you and I have talked about it
before I think I'm some of our previous
ones but the typical experience you know
of the American consumer II now as you
wake up on a mattress that's off gassing
carcinogens and you go and you wash
yourself down with a bunch of chemically
infused soaps and and skin products that
have on average 180 different chemicals
by the time you've gotten out of the
house you put on makeup that's got
another 185 chemicals in it and then you
stumble into your car and the car is off
gas and plastic in air conditions and
you're driving down a highway that's
steeped in and you heard pollution then
you get to your office and you take a
few steps outside into the office and
that you're in a closed air conditioned
space and you in a carpeted cubicle and
off-gassing junk again and then you go
to the grocery store and you pick up
food that you have came from half a
world away and got transported picked
unripe and transported under ethylene
gas so it so it ripen and then now
you're eating what looks like a kale
salad but it's actually loaded with
roundup and you know it just goes on and
on that's can you believe we're even
surviving that should we be surprised
that were following a human being like
that is incredibly resilient to be able
to not only survive really speaks to the
procreate and thrive in that environment
so far um you know interestingly we're
not thriving and we're not procreating
very well anymore right it's not to
bring that up it's worth saying that the
sperm counts in all Western countries
have dropped by 52 to 57 percent in in
my short lifetime and so we are now
seeing one in three males with
sperm counts less than 15 million per
milliliter which is the infertility
level and so we are that kerb hasn't
flattened it out that's a straight line
towards the bottom and it has not
leveled off and so we're that's that's
the extinction event is we're losing the
capacity to procreate
we're losing the capacity for human life
and we're when we are alive we burden it
with chronic disease levels that have
never been seen before from autism and
our children to Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's of our elderly our cancer
burden now at 50% it's just like you we
are failing as a biologic species
because of the collapse of biology
beneath our feet beneath our gut beneath
the soils that dwell around us and so
we're we're in the throes of an
extinction event
we're losing 10,000 times increase in
our extinction rate to the point where
we're losing a species every 20 minutes
and that's all happened in the last
three decades and the dominant feature
that is certainly chemical farming so I
can't push hard enough for you for you
embracing farmers footprint as an
audience take a look at everything we're
doing this in touches your backyard
again we're just scaling up non-toxic
neighborhoods that was created by
brilliant woman Kim Conti and she was
just a concerned mother in Irvine
California and she came back from living
abroad for many years and brought her
young kids back into Irvine California
and then started seeing signs posted
about stay off the grass for 24 24 hours
because it's been sprayed and she was
alarmed she's like what are we spraying
on these find out that we're spraying
all of our playing fields and Parks with
Roundup and she was extremely dismayed
and started to non toxic neighborhoods
and has done a beautiful job over 35
cities and counties around the country
including LA County and now San Diego
County just in the last couple weeks
Miami many others around the country
have gotten roundup free or implementing
roundup bans in their public places
parks and city spaces and playing fields
etc and so that's part of the farmers
footprint you can dig in at farmers
footprint dot us and realize that the
third larger crop we grow in the United
States right behind corn and soybean is
lon and so the backyard lawn is our
third largest crop covering 40 million
of acres of the United States and it's
one of our most chemically demanding
crops that we do and that starts in your
backyard but extends to your children's
soccer fields football fields playing
fields and perhaps the most toxic thing
we see in all of that acreage is the the
golf courses and so if you're a golfer
you need to start to really work to
revise the the practices we need to
redefine our aesthetics of golf back to
where it was in Ireland where a rough
was a rough it was it was a cover crop
out there there was multiple species it
was grassland it wasn't you know a
monoculture of Kentucky bluegrass
growing a little bit longer we need to
start to redefine these these nature
spaces that we we spend time on and get
them clean and join non-toxic
neighborhoods in the fight there it's
exciting to see consumers and making
real success with local government when
the federal government continues to be
so resistant to change the EPA just
again proved roundup for another 13
years of use in the United States save
and that the evidence is not strong
enough to say that it's dangerous to
public health which is just ludicrous at
this point but I'm just grateful that
our local leaders are not agreeing with
that and are taking strong stands with
our with our concerned parents and
cleaning up our environment so we got a
lot to be excited about there and in the
end I think that all of us are gonna
create the change we want to see if we
can see the problem at hand well I'm
grateful for the work that you're doing
that you will do that you have done and
this has been as edifying and
illuminating as as I predicted it would
and I think I want to close just by
saying you know kind of calling out to
the audience to really remind everybody
that we are in an unprecedented moment
right now and my hope my aspiration is
that it will provide us with the
necessary pause that I think is required
to reflect on systems gone awry and what
is broken and non functioning in our
society right now
and give us the bandwidth and the
opportunity to imagine the better more
sustainable and ecologically sound world
that I think is well within our grasp
absolutely that's beautiful I also you
know they want to just close with
reaching out to the physicians and
nurses and nurse practitioners and for
the PAS that are out there right now on
the frontlines in New York and
Philadelphia and all the other cities
that are starting to see the impact of
this the situation we're in right now
and I just want to you know acknowledge
your effort and the fear that you're
feeling and the exhaustion you're
feeling and the state of overwhelm that
you sense and the vulnerabilities that
you're you know so poignant Lee aware of
right at the moment and I just want you
to know that we so deeply appreciate
your commitment and your efforts in this
time we know the extremity of the
situation you're in and look forward to
the end of that in the coming weeks as
as this passes over us and in the
meantime I just want to reflect for a
moment about again redefining your role
just like we did with the garden we need
to let go of
maybe the expectations that you're going
to heal everybody and you're going to
save everybody's life and we need to
really look at both sides of the
physician our care teams experience on
the one side we are all trained to be
technicians now we're trained to adjust
the knobs on the ventilators we're
trained to adjust the drips on the IVs
we're trained to read all the data and
we're trained to write all the notes and
look at all the risk factors and fill
out the insurance forms all of that is
coming to a crisis point that's not
working and that happens every day in an
ICU where all the technology at hands
finally fails and there's nothing more
we can offer in the patient's die and
then there's a second half to the
journey that is the definition of that
being a physician state or being a
caretaker being a nurse is when you set
down the machinery and you sit down with
the patient and say we've done our best
we have done everything we know how to
do and we acknowledge that you are alive
and we acknowledge that you are here
with us in this moment and we
acknowledge that you're gonna likely
expand to the other side of this rebirth
that we call death and in that time with
your patience right now I want you to
know that we see the greatest victory
right there because ultimately as
physicians and practitioners we don't
actually save lives we don't have that
level of capacity or responsibility life
is something much greater than human
life is a gift and it's not your
responsibility to maintain it it's your
responsibility up and bring the highest
level compassion skill capacity that you
can but you will do your highest work
when you recognize that this miraculous
life that we live this miraculous gift
of life is transient it is temporal and
it is our calling to be present with
that and acknowledge it and see the
beauty in every phase of it and when
you've got a young person who's dying or
an elderly person who's dying it's easy
to get caught up in the emotions of the
loss but we need to get better and
celebrate the moment of acknowledging
the gain this is a life well-lived this
is a person who has you know created in
their lifetimes the person who's loved
in their lifetime this is a person who's
really in it for them for the big big
story of what it means to be human and
this was a soul that came in on purpose
and has lived some version of that
purpose and we acknowledge that and so I
hope that in the same way that the mess
of messy garden can start to look like a
victory the mess of healthcare it can be
very victorious if we recognize each
other's humanity in it and if we really
embrace the beauty of human life and
consciousness that becomes often most
poignant and most obvious when we're
about to lose it and we let go that
human consciousness to plug into
something much much bigger and I hope
that you get to see as the the veil
thins with your patients right now I get
to get to see that other side and
realize that they have no fear on the
other side of that veil it's
they're coming back and forth out of
consciousness and back into
consciousness in those last few minutes
and hours and days I hope that you get a
glimpse of the beauty on the other side
and a state of being that's free of fear
free of sense of loss and only sees the
opportunity and expansion and light and
so take take this opportunity to like
down the expectations on yourself and
give up on a sense of failure let go of
your sense of failure in those moments
when the ventilators failing auctions
failing the numbers are going south
don't let that define your your success
be present with your patience right now
let let them not die in vain
let them be part of the message that
this virus is trying to teach us let
their journey be part of you reach out
to them and hold their hands right now
and give them a sense of deep purpose in
this extreme thing that they've been
called to if they're called to pass
right now let them know it's not in vain
that we're gonna learn from this that we
are realizing that we have taken too
many steps away from our purpose our
real nature our real potential and that
they are doing their highest work right
now in walking the journey of dying in
this situation to teach us a deep lesson
of what it means to be connected and
disconnected and a pathway towards
reconnection and let them know that
their highest victory is at hand
and and that they are part of the rise
of human consciousness and not the
collapse of biology on planet that's
that's what I want you to grab right now
and um just know that I just am in deep
gratitude for your courage to keep
showing up love you brother thank you I
appreciate you Thank You reg for I never
know what to expect whenever I free to
do one of these with you it never turns
out like I expect but that was beautiful
for being so
present and a lovely love letter to the
people that are on the front lines who
are seeing the suffering firsthand and
suffering themselves so that's much
needed in this conversation right now
and so thank you for that I think it's
going to be very helpful to a lot of
people and more will be revealed hmm
more will be revealed that's hopeful
right so perhaps we'll do this again I'd
like to check in with you and see how
you're doing and and let's stay in touch
I look forward to it all right thank you
rich and thank you everybody in this
audience you've had such an impact on my
life thank you for the hope you've
brought me and the joy you've brought me
and thank you for your continued
engagement until next time thanks man
thank you
peace plants mind-blowing is always how
much do we love Zach Busch hope you guys
enjoyed that and that you take Zach's
wisdom to heart you can learn more about
Zach at Zach Busch MD com4 his written
perspective on coronavirus and
recommended resources visit Zach Bush MD
com forward slash coronavirus -
statement and for those interested in
regenerative farming and Zach's
nonprofit initiatives that we discussed
today visit farmers footprint dot us
Zach also wanted me to mention that his
biology Basecamp home health programs
including a new program released just
this week at a lower price called
biology Basecamp community can be found
at intrinsic health series.com
as always links to all the four
mentioned and much more can be found on
the episode page at rich WorldCom and if
you would like to support the work we do
here on the show subscribe rate and
comment on it on Apple podcasts Spotify
and YouTube share the show or your
favorite episodes with friends are on
social media and you can support us on
patreon at
trol calm forward-slash donate I want to
thank my team who worked hard to put on
today's show Jason cami yellow for audio
engineering production show notes and
interstitial music Blake Curtis and
Margo Lubin who typically video the
podcast although today is audio only
Jessica Miranda for her beautiful
graphics Leia MERIS ovitch for her
portraits of Zack and myself
Georgia Whaley for copywriting DK for
advertiser relationships and theme music
by Tyler PI at trapper Pyatt and Hari
Mathis thanks for the love you guys see
you back here in a couple days with our
regularly scheduled programming until
then be safe stay safe take care of
yourselves and seize this moment to go
inward to grow and to love more deeply
peace plants